from mortgage prices to hospital
pressures
the problems facing the government are
complex and often connected
this week as the Health Service nears
its 75th Anniversary the Prime Minister
will unveil a long-awaited Workforce
plan pitched as the biggest expansion in
staff training in the nhs's history
writing in the Sunday Times Rishi sunak
said it will be a 15-year plan to give
the NHS certainty because we recognize
it takes time to train these staff who
are among the most highly skilled in our
society and it will be backed by
Government funding and support balanced
Against The Wider pressures on the
economy
but with the longest Junior doctor
strike yet due next month and teachers
set to walk out over pay as well
short-term Solutions are also needed
they could be hard to come by though
this Minister suggesting the treasury
may not follow independent pay rise
advice for these sectors if it's deemed
to be too high as a matter of principle
pay review bodies are a very significant
part of resolving the the pay issues but
obviously we've also got to take account
of the effect on inflation I don't think
anyone wants to see strikes across any
of our public services but what the
government's got to do is take
responsible decisions on public spending
in the round
for Downing Street a prolonged standoff
with unions is yet another side effect
of its increasingly heated battle
against Rising prices with inflation
still stubbornly high and interest rates
increasing again this has been a bleak
week for number 10. Rishi sunak today
urged homeowners to hold their nerve
over soaring mortgage costs but with a
general election around the corner
voters are being asked to put up with a
lot of pain what are you doing to help
you with their mortgages meeting lenders
on Friday the chancellor has set out
some help for struggling homeowners but
has stopped short of providing direct
payments labor wouldn't get out the
checkbook either but it's still calling
for a more muscular approach we estimate
that significant numbers of people won't
be able to access any support at all
unless the measures become mandatory so
that all mortgage payers not just some
have access to these measures that give
them more flexibility to extend mortgage
terms to be able to shift from one type
of mortgage to another
curbing Rising prices is now seen as the
linchpin without which progress in other
areas will stay stunted but economics
and politics may not align a prime
minister shorts on options and short on
time
news in Westminster